what's up guys I am back from college
and I'm super excited to start making
videos in the summer and now that it's
summer I'm gonna start trying to make at
least 2 to 3 videos a week and if you
guys have any feedback or any comments
or anything just leave in the comments
as always and let's get started what's
up guys I got a great money-making
method for you guys and I found this
mining method just by making maple
saplings I was making them to plant them
because I am at 45 farming which is the
requirement for this method and I
realized that the maple happens were
actually about 5k more than the maple
seeds so basically to make these you
need fill potted plants maple seeds
trowel and then some watering cans that
have some water in them and so you put
the seeds in the in the filled potted
plants and then after you do that you
put the watering cans on it and you fill
them up and then well I'll go ahead and
see how long it takes for them to fill
up and then tell you guys and then we'll
go ahead and sell them and see how much
might make
all right they're done and I start the
timer and it's at 4 minutes 28 seconds
so it took about three minutes to do
that
so take about three minutes per
inventory just keep that in mind if
you're doing it and we'll go ahead and
sell them we'll sell them instantly and
they sold for 50k each so that's about
5k more than I sold them I originally
bought them for so we'll do the 750 K -
what I bought them for six seventy four
[Music]
nine four zero okay so 75 K
so we'll divide 60 minutes divided by
the four and a half minutes total it
took let me get 13 so we'll times that
by the 75k we made
so one mil so you can easily make one
with this method and if you do it at the
right time and you do a quick enough you
can easily make one mil to two 1.2 mil
so thanks for watching guys can't wait
til the next video
[Music]